[Music]
the hardest part about brexit
is the borders as part of the european
union
the united kingdom's borders have been
relatively open for years
trades carried out freely with other
member countries and people coming
through
only need to show their eu passport but
in june 2016
the uk voted to leave the eu so that it
could reassert control on its own
borders
and decide who and what it wanted to let
through imagine these boundaries turning
into hard borders
the impact of that on these maritime
borders is complicated in terms of trade
but it could have serious implications
for the people living along the uk's
only overland border
here this border between northern
ireland and the republic of ireland
is one of the reasons why brexit
negotiations continue to reach a
deadlock
that's because this isn't just a
boundary between two countries
it's also a compromise a symbol of
identity
a solution to a troubled history and
it's been keeping the peace in northern
ireland for 20 years
hardening this border could put one of
europe's greatest success stories
in jeopardy
[Applause]
[Music]
this border was first drawn in 1920 by
the british who had ruled over the
island for centuries
the irish had rebelled several times but
not everyone wanted the british to leave
so eventually the uk divided the island
into two states based on its population
most people in this part were
historically catholic identified as
irish and wanted independents
they were known as nationalists but in
the north many people were protestant
identified more closely as british and
wanted to stay in the uk
they were called unionists after the
partition this part remained in the uk
as northern ireland
we made that decision as a people quite
freely
and for very definite reasons reasons
that are historical
reasons that are cultural and reasons
that are
economic the south continued to move
away from the uk until it gained
complete independence
and became a new country the republic of
ireland
at first this 499 kilometer border was
pretty porous
but the uk and ireland continued to be
hostile over time customs checks were
set up at the border crossings
and the two countries descended into a
trade war tariffs were placed on
agricultural produce
and goods like steel and coal by the
late 1960s
things turned violent violence like this
hit northern ireland after years of
simmering bitterness between the
catholic minority
and the ruling protestant regime in
northern ireland fierce conflict broke
out between extremist groups
nationalist paramilitaries like the
irish republican army
believed that northern ireland was
rightfully part of ireland and that the
british were oppressors of northern
ireland's nationalist population
unionist paramilitaries fought back
defending their place in the uk
both groups blew up buildings set off
car bombs and engaged in bloody street
fighting
the uk deployed thousands of troops to
northern ireland during his time
and became a common target of
nationalist paramilitary attacks
especially at the border which for
nationalists was the ultimate symbol of
british occupation
welsh fusiliers who patrol this stretch
of the border described in court as the
main battle line between the ira and the
army
have suffered repeated attacks as
violence surged
the uk military tried to secure the
border with walls towers heavy guns and
patrols
they tightly controlled the 20 official
crossings and screened people and
vehicles passing through
the conflict in northern ireland turned
this into a hard border
the violence lasted for more than 30
years killed over 3 600 people
and came to be known as the troubles it
came to an end in 1998
when the nationalists and unionist party
leaders came together for a historic
peace deal
they reached a compromise northern
ireland would remain in the uk
but people would be eligible for both
irish and uk citizenships
and in the future northern ireland could
vote to join ireland
this deal came to be known as the good
friday agreement it allowed nationalists
in northern ireland to be part of the
republic of ireland
while the unionists remained part of the
uk which meant that this hard border
wasn't needed anymore
so the british military left the
watchtowers came down
and more roads opened there are now
around 270 official crossings
most of which are completely invisible
and they're all part of a border that
stands as a symbol of the compromise
that ended decades of conflict
the british people have voted to leave
the european union reignited a fierce
debate over northern ireland's future
because both are members of the european
union but when britain pulls out of the
eu
it's now an outer eu border and the
question is do we put a barbed wire
again of soldiers if they'll be a
customs border
at the very least in june 2016 the uk
voted to leave the eu
even though northern ireland was
overwhelmingly in favor of remaining
the uk's argument in favor of brexit was
to control its own
national borders but there was little
mention of its irish border at the time
that changed when the uk and eu started
negotiations
the status of the irish border became
one of the first three things to figure
out
now more than a year later it's still
unresolved but there are a few options
the uk could reimpose a hard border by
bringing back the police and the walls
but that would isolate the population of
nationalists in northern ireland
alternatively they could put the border
here leaving northern ireland in the eu
customs union but separating it from the
uk mainland but this would betray the
unionists
see either way both of these options
risk violating the good friday agreement
a third option is for the uk to stay in
the eu customs union
meaning it wouldn't need a customs
border but that's unacceptable for
brexiteers in the uk government
who specifically want control over their
own borders
the uk needs to put a border somewhere
but just can't decide where
on relation to the uh border of between
northern ireland and ireland
we will not return to a hard border
between northern ireland island but the
suggestion that there should be a border
down
the irish sea separating northern
ireland from the rest of the united
kingdom
is completely unacceptable we are not
going to be in a customs union we're not
going to be in the customs union
because if we were that would prevent us
from being able to follow an independent
trade policy
now there's a fourth option that would
be in line with the good friday
agreement
it's the idea of reunification in the
past when both ireland and the uk were
in the eu
and the borders were open there was
little incentive for northern ireland to
vote to reunite with the republic of
ireland
but if the uk went with the option of
hard borders northern ireland would be
isolated and the only way to rejoin the
eu would be through reunification
typically this would be an overwhelming
victory for the nationalists and the
loss for the unionists
but brexit seems to have changed some
opinions a recent poll found that 28
of respondents who supported northern
ireland's place in the uk
would now vote to join the republic of
ireland
while not a perfect solution it would
give northern ireland a voice about its
own place in europe
a voice that's barely been heard so far
[Music]
you